[Music]
[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw
as the status symbol of choice ken
coleman ramsey personality
host of the ken coleman show is my
co-host today
as we talk about your life and your
money open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight
eight two five five two two five ken on
the ken coleman show talks about careers
and jobs and
getting in the position that you want
every year
or that you want for the rest of your
life that is show
they said you talked about it on your
percent of the
workforce in america is looked of the
workforce in america
is looking to change jobs this year
so here we are as we are approaching you
know halfway through and
they're going hey i'm going to make a
move so you're going to see this in 2021
and 2022 a lot of people changing jobs
you talk about
25 is the low end of the survey 40
percent that's an extraordinary number
of people who are saying you know what
it's time to make a change certainly
brought on by the
pandemic giving you a philosophical
reset and saying
life's too short to work it's something
i hate with people i hate that's right
here's what happens
so we know that change is one of the
greatest concerns for any human being
change is scary it has all this unknown
and so change is really really ugly
however when a forced
change happens to you so let's take the
pandemic and it was a massive change for
people
in largely uh i mean arguably the
largest area of their life you think
about time you spend at home
with family friends sleeping you think
about work that's the thing you spend
most time on your life and so when
there's a force change you didn't have
any
choice you were sent home either
furloughed laid off or you were working
from home
so now all of a sudden you're
confronting a change that you had no
choice over
and now you're dealing with that change
and so then we begin to go oh
wow this is huge what other parts of my
life would i like to change
and i think that's what has happened
collectively people are going
well i had to deal with this what would
it look like if i actually worked in a
place that i really love what if i did
work that mattered deeply to me
what would i have to do what if i change
some things to be able to get qualified
to make more money what if i paid off
debt
and i think you're seeing people are
going you know what
i think it's time i think it's time and
i'm going to move here's what's
interesting with this
40 of america workers are considering
moving into something else so they're
going to quit their current job
and you got 9.3 million jobs dave that
that are open
right now and and so it is a
good time is the point because companies
are needing talent they want talent
yeah but if you're one of these
companies with no soul
you can take advantage of people and no
people aren't going to come no that's
true to end up with a labor shortage
well we already have that absolutely i
mean you're going to end up not being
able
because these folks are what we're
saying is is that
because of the pandemic they said life's
too short and that's what the surveys
are indicating
yeah um that that they're not going to
go to work for
a company where life's too short again
that's true they're going to go they
want to do some plug into something
where
they matter where the work matters and
where is something that they have
actually have a freaking talent at that
they're not just there to collect a
check
that's right they have realized like
crucial driven organizations like ramsey
that's it
see we all along i think benefit from
this we will benefit from it i'm gonna
tell you this the ken coleman show
uh in ramsey solutions we're positioned
to help a lot of people make this move
because now they they need to know what
they're looking for some of them don't
know they're just going
this isn't it and so what we teach every
day as you know dave on the day
on the ken coleman show is hey you use
talent
as your tool your talent our premium
tools you do work you love we call that
passion
you just love the work and then that
work creates a result that matters
deeply to you so when we hire people
ramsey solutions here's what you've got
to be you got to be a crusader
you have to be deeply deeply committed
to the results of hope practical paths
forward for people
to turn their life around whether it be
on the dr john dolani show
with your mental emotional health they
can't go turn your career around
uh or turn your money life around and so
when you come here you better be
missional and you better care about the
result
of life change hope practical steps
forward for people
well you won't make it through the
interview process and if you did you
won't fit in
no if you lie to us if you want to just
collect you will be exposed because you
this is a different place
yeah well i mean we we
we were talking about that this morning
and snapping we this is how we
do things and not everybody needs to be
a we that's true
you know so you mean if you if you want
to just
say well i've got a degree in x and so i
have a s
i have a talent yeah and you should just
pay me for delivering on that talent
yeah
nope yeah it's not going to happen nope
that's why we're getting so many
developers coming
oh yeah because develop we work a
developer uh 40 hours a week not 80.
that's right and we work a developer uh
where they're writing code
doing something that matters and so when
they woke up during the pandemic they
didn't wake up and go i hate my job they
woke up and went man we've got a lot of
people need our help yeah that's exactly
right
and so they're going hey i know that if
i'm in here in this company coding
that it is going to be directly tied to
transformation
see i think that's that's what everybody
wants is to make a difference in the
work
so the net result will be
for the economy overall if this
transition is accurate
if this survey is accurate will be a
huge increase in productivity
because people will leave jobs in
bad situations that they are not good at
that they're not passionate about and go
plug into something
yes a that they're good at and b they're
passionate about in a better situation
and they'll produce more way more which
in goods and services which will help
the economy overall
so really if people everyone followed
the ken coleman rule
and got in something where their talent
and their passion was aligned with what
they were doing every day
then the economy would boom even more
productivity rises
and durability increases people stay
longer
tenure people will stay in a place where
they go my
work matters the company sees me dave
you just touched on this
underneath all of this is a massive
warning to leaders
and to companies that if you don't give
people
a connection to their work if they can't
see that you care deeply about them
because they could be in their sweet
spot
talent passion mission aligned but if
you have a crappy culture
they will leave you they will leave you
and
and and you better have a place that uh
is is healthy and you better have a
place
that is dominated by leaders who care
for their people and people feel like
hey you see me i'm not just doing work
that matters to me but i matter to you
because you share how
we collectively everybody at ram
solutions matters to the world out there
that's what's special about this place
and companies that don't figure this out
you're going to lose talent
at an alarming rate and the companies
that figure this out dave
are going to explode they're going to
grow like crazy
yeah and one of the things that they
came to the conclusion i disagree with
was that
the worker is now demanding that they
work from home yeah
well those people are going to lose yeah
that's not going to work bad idea by the
way it's not going to work
yeah uh it hasn't worked you could try
all of the data
new is in that's right and work from
home doesn't equal work
no getting done can't have a great
culture
if everybody's separated all the time
yeah and it's we're seeing
major companies that thought they were
going to go that way swinging back now
again this is the third time we've gone
through this
watch this wave go back and forth and
i've been unpopular every time because
we don't work from home we work from
here with human beings
in the building where we can see each
[Music]
[Music]
other
[Music]
[Music]
let's
still on baby step number one huh how'd
you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget
don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
you know what sucks
living paycheck to paycheck where you
have too much
much month left at the end of the money
you're barely covering the bills you're
never getting ahead you feel like a
rat stuck in a wheel run run run run run
run
you don't have to live like this stop
going in circles it's time to start
making progress
check out ramsey plus this membership
will show you
how to make the changes you need
to get the results that you want with
your money
and that's because ramsey plus gives you
complete access to our best
online money courses like financial
peace university
know yourself know your money and tools
like every dollar that actually makes
sense get out of the cycle
start making real progress jump in on
your free trial
at ramsey plus today text trial
to 33 789 text trial
233.789
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two
five janet starts off this hour in
pittsburgh
hey janet how are you i'm great how are
you
better than i deserve what's up better
than you deserve i know it i've been
listening to you and following
since um the 90s but
through financial peace yeah yeah
back in 2009 and again in 2012
when i was living with my husband we
paid off 167
000 in debt but got right back in
i separated from him 16 months ago
got a restraining order and the kids and
i have been living on our own since then
i have two at home out of six
wow um the other four are grown up
so i'm 56 i earn including child support
about 57 five a year i have two jobs
one is i work for a person with autism
as an aide
and another one is i work in an
emotional support therapeutic classroom
as a paraprofessional the second job i'm
not crazy about there's a lot of danger
there
and i'm getting older so
i paid off my last debt my car on
thursday of last week way to go
um yes and so i'm debt-free
yeah and i took the rest of the money
from the settlement from the house that
we sold
during this huge market boom we sold the
marital residence and i put the rest
and funded my baby step three good so i
i feel like i took two huge steps and i
don't know quite what to do
there's still some money left over i'm
putting it in a
fund to save up for a down payment for a
house
perfect i would like to move from
pittsburgh and move back home
or some place where they have fantastic
jobs like you guys do
okay where you don't have to worry about
a kid carrying a switchblade into school
i got you you know well that's pretty
well anywhere these days but yeah okay
so i'm i'm done with funding college and
all of that that's
you know my daughter is probably going
to go into the air force we don't have
to worry about that
my son that lives with me pays rent and
i'm trying to figure out i mean have
everything budgeted
i just want to figure out how to do this
house thing right without screwing it up
because i'm going to be going back into
debt and i just got out of debt
so i want to do it you know i'm thinking
maybe a fifty thousand dollar house
maybe eighty where is that home that
you're talking about moving to
oh erie pennsylvania all right and
uh on the lake and can you uh
uh buy a house for fifty thousand
dollars in erie pennsylvania
you still can but the problem is the
challenging thing is the employment
market
okay all right that's that's the thing
now my one job will go with me
um but my other job you know that's
twenty three thousand dollars worth of
income that i have to replace
really with what i do that's not who is
an eerie better than that
i have family there but mostly it's the
familiarity it's um
you know i could go pretty much anywhere
but i don't have another landing pad
that's what i was um i have a girlfriend
who lives down in north carolina that
the
rate of living there is so expensive and
i don't think
that my second job would transfer down
there
if the job situation need working i'm an
aide working for my son
and that's funded in pennsylvania so i'm
golden in pennsylvania
yeah janet i was going to ask you really
quickly is if the eerie job situation
was just a snap it was already taken
care of
would that be your favorite place of all
the places you could go yeah
okay so so how much
extra money if we remove the second job
where you're in the classroom is
essentially a parapro
um how much money do we need to replace
on that particular job how much
23 000 okay i could drive a bus yeah you
know and make more than that there's a
lot you could do yeah so let me ask you
this and i don't
the thing that that gives me summers off
with my son i have a 21 year old son
with autism
gotcha so ideally you want the summers
off
so what could you do yeah well that's
ideal correct
all right so here's what i'm trying to
walk you through i want you to have an
ideal list okay so i ideally if i could
get a job in the school system that's
not as
scary as the pair pro in these in these
classrooms
uh with some of these kids um that's
ideal
but then we say okay let's look for
what's there let's just not assume that
as well it's a horrible job market in
erie the mistake by the lake it's what
you call it you've kind of poo-pooed the
whole area
so let's see what's there that's an idea
yeah i know uh
and so well let's look at ideal and then
we look at okay
what could i do that would still give me
a life and my 21 year old son
i mean i'm going to work 40 hours and
make really good money i can make more
than 23.
and i think you've got to ask yourself
what can i do well let's just start with
the tools
we look at talent here at ramsey
solutions as
a tool that i can use to do work that i
enjoy so start with
hey i'm really organized i'm really good
with people you need to just do a quick
assessment
and and i want you to go to kencole.com
and get the career clarity guide simple
little worksheet
it allows you to get feedback from
people who know you really well so you
get some confidence on this
but just begin to identify another day
job that you can do well
that's in a better environment and now
you're there with family
you're saving up and you're you're
getting that house a lot quicker than
you realize but don't assume
uh that something's not there until you
dig into it because there's a lot of
work in area that she can do dave
and make more than 23. yeah continue to
save on your baby step 3b
for a down payment on a house when you
move to the area you do not have to buy
a house immediately
you can rent for a little while and
let's get all these career boxes
checked and your income and even
support boxes checked and maybe
north carolina is there that's right i
will tell you there are sections of
north carolina that are
less expensive than erie pennsylvania
your your set of assumptions there is
just not accurate
so you've assumed that everything in
aries are bleak and horrible including
prices on houses
and then everything in north carolina is
the land of uh
you know plenty and and expensive and
it's
neither one of those is completely true
there are some
good spots that you can pick in erie and
land in and some good jobs that you can
pick there
and the same would be true of north
carolina and so these blanket statements
now i do think the reason you want to go
to erie and what familiar is after going
through this divorce
and all this pain uh you want a familiar
place to heal
and i'm perfectly okay with that idea
that's fine the familiarity part of your
statement was
absolutely truth that was very good
so you know begin to find something make
a move
there is nothing if you go rent and get
a job there's nothing to say that
you don't find a better job in a
different place later
and move again that none of this is is
none of these are forever decisions so
you got to get on a path here
that gets you um you know heading
in a direction of a career and a house
and i and those are not incongruent with
where you are i think you can get there
i really do
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple a eight two
five
five two five when you're faced with a
set of
decisions like they can we teach
decision making is in one of the
leadership things in entree leadership
there's a couple of things that that uh
that
when you get emotional whether you're
wounded
angry whether you're hurt
uh whatever emotion you want to put out
there you
shut down your peripheral vision and you
fail to see as many
options for the way around something you
get tunnel vision
and options the more options you have
when you're making any decision the
better likelihood you're going to make
the right decision
when you start saying absolutes like
there's no jobs there
or that's area is just always expensive
these are absolute statements that are
inaccurate
and that's coming out of your pain this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
adam and victoria are with us hey guys
how are you
i'm pretty good good welcome it's a
pleasure to have you guys
where do you all live bluff city
tennessee bluff city did you say
yes okay like kingsport area huh yeah
yes okay cool well welcome to nashville
good to have you guys and all the way
over here to the other end of the state
to do a debt-free scream
how much have you paid off 67 000 15
months
67 000 15 months and your range of
income during that time it's about 60 to
65
000. cool what do y'all do for a living
i'm a subaru technician
at a dealership and i work in a deli
okay i thought maybe he did voiceover i
i was gonna
it's got pipes man got pipes most of my
subaru technicians don't have pipes like
that i'm just saying
good man way to go what kind of debt was
the 65 000
uh it was actually let's just say half
of it was a student loans
and then there was a car that we
basically got rid of and then
uh what was it credit cards and tool
loans
and you did all of this in 15 months
what happened to you guys 15 months ago
let you on fire like this
you got after it yeah we um we did the
financial peace program
and after that my parents let us live
that freddy
or rent free we're not free to be that
friend
okay cool so you've been with them for a
little while are you out yet
uh well we're actually uh living in one
of their uh what was it the cabin
oh okay and uh so it's just basically
just uh victoria and i
oh i saw so you know
trying to pay all the loans off you know
that was a feat
but now since we uh basically become uh
debt free
uh we're saving up for a home good way
to go you guys thank you fun what
what inspired you to take financial
peace university uh well
uh her uh mother kind of convinced us to
uh take the cl
the course and she uh she basically said
hey you know
we'll pay for the course if you go if
you don't go then you owe me money
wow so you know that's that's fair
it's a fair trade sure you got to show
up after i pay for it
yeah that's all right how long y'all
been married a year and a half
oh wow okay so that's the first order of
business then after marriage boom
yeah go go to financial peace get
married get out of debt just like that
boom how old are you two i'm 28
29 next month oh and i'll be 31 tomorrow
yay and no payments in the world whose
student loans was it
it was all mine all yours okay and it
was your mom
uh victoria that paid for the course yes
so she's straightening out her
son-in-law here
i love it that's great i love a meddling
mother-in-law
she's awesome that's so fun good for her
and good for you guys for listening i'm
proud of you it took a little bit of
humility to do that
i'm proud of you there adam that was
very very cool
and so you step in say we're gonna get
married we're gonna clean this mess up
and you just went wide open huh this is
correct
yeah so what do you tell people the key
to getting out of that is well
it's just mostly uh you know when you're
given a opportunity
such as what we were blessed with uh
you know a lot of people would not take
advantage of that
you know they might actually try to you
know buy cars
and all this other stuff but you know
for us we just had to buckle down
and the whole thing with you know the
beans and rice you know
with our budget we had to get rid of the
rice and it kind of put a stress on our
marriage a little bit there just beans
huh
oh yeah we won't ask any follow-up
questions i don't need to know
any more about this yeah way too much
information for me
fun fun very fun so when you started
taking the class
what was maybe something that caught you
off guard you didn't expect that maybe
something you never thought of or
something so common sense you're like
how did i not see this
i think it's more of uh you know the the
snowball
you know just learning how to actually
go through the whole program
you know uh that was probably i would
say the common sense part but
it really did not you know register to
me but
i know when we uh took the course uh
you know it's when you're looking at the
big picture
you know not the small picture it's it
makes sense
you know it's like hey you know if i'm
debt-free or we're debt-free
you know uh we pretty much just do
anything we want
we don't have anybody uh holding us back
or anything like that
so very cool and that gave you the fire
to go do it then
yeah good way to go you guys i'm so
proud of y'all
thank you thank you proud of you who are
your biggest cheerleaders
my whole family yeah your family i would
have to say her okay and her family yeah
all right so it's kind of a financial
peace thing getting out of debt things
kind of a family thing for your family
yes
okay very neat very neat wow
excellent excellent excellent well done
you guys
so well done i'm proud of you we got a
copy of the book
the legacy journey which is what your
family has engaged in
changing their legacy and you're part of
that legacy and now you're going to
extend it on
and we're going to give you an extra
copy of the book the total money
makeover to give to other friends and
maybe you can inspire them to get on the
journey with you
and uh get get to going and they can be
where you are how does it feel now that
you're completely free
good wonderful just like that i love it
oh yeah
very fun well way to go you guys
congratulations adam and victoria
from the kingsport tennessee area bluff
city count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three
two one we're there free yeah
very well done
very well done mary is in mcallen texas
hi
mary how can we help today hi dave
thanks for taking my call how are you
better than i deserve how can we help
um well i just finished um baby step
three
i'm gonna go ahead and start on baby
step four soon
um i was able to incorporate baby step
six into my baby step three so the house
is paid as well
um however i'd like to open
my own business but it is
pretty expensive my six month savings
would not cover it at all
how would i be able to get all the money
i need without taking out
a large loan and using the home as
collateral
let me tell you that the number one
reason that 80 percent of the small
businesses fail in the first five years
cash flow problems you know cash flow
problems are created by
not paying your taxes properly and they
come down around your head and
debt so here's what you do
you don't open this business the way
you're thinking of doing it
we have to figure out another way to get
at this what kind of business are you
talking about
i'd like to open my own rock climbing
gym
okay all right and um
so that is a very high risk endeavor
i don't mean falling off the rock i mean
risk
i mean the business failing high risk
their 100 of rock climbing gyms do not
succeed as a matter of fact a very
small percentage of them succeed because
people make the mistake of thinking
i install rock climbing and people will
show up a
field of dreams if i build it they will
come and that
is complete bs it does not work that way
so what do you do for a living now
i'm an administrative assistant okay ken
why the rock climbing tell me the why
not don't explain the whole business to
me but why did you think of that when
you thought of a company
um it's the only thing i ever
really felt maybe passionate about the
only thing i've ever enjoyed
doing i don't want to continue working
for
someone else i want to work for myself
and
okay so i do agree with that i want to
help you do that so
you do climb you do climbs in nature now
not on a wall
right i prefer
indoor over outdoor however
the fact of the matter is you like being
outdoor you like adventure
sports you probably like hiking is that
true or false
yes i enjoy that all right so if you
don't want to work for anybody else
and you love outdoor adventure and all
that type of stuff what i'd like to see
you do
is stay stable you've done such a great
job getting where you are
let's get a second job but now this time
it's not about getting out debt
let's get a a side hustle that's in that
space and you probably will work for
somebody for a season
but let's take people on hikes let's do
some uh
outdoor uh you know outriggers people
are doing that kind of work
that kind of work and find some indoor
rock climbing gyms and see how
you can serve them how you can get
involved on their staff temporarily yeah
but i'm with you dave i mean she
ultimately loves that outdoor adventure
side of things
she like climbing the rocks and what
inside she said yeah i know but we both
said that
rock climbing gyms aren't a good idea so
i want to get her i'm not sure i want to
buy one i know i don't want to go from
administrative assistant to owning one
that's true
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
ernest is in kansas city hi ernest how
are you
doing pretty good dave how are you
better than i deserve how can we help
uh hi i was just wondering what can i do
to
kind of protect the money we've saved
from inflation
where is it saved uh we're just
in savings accounts basically right now
how much is in there
uh 10 000 in the house fund
about 20 000 in the emergency fund okay
the emergency fund you don't protect
from inflation that's not what it's for
it's there just for insurance so when
life happens
transmission goes out somebody gets sick
somebody gets laid off
that's what it's for it's not it's not
an investment investments have to be
protected from inflation
by investing at a rate of return
that is higher than the inflation rate
and that's what you have to do you have
to make the inflation rate is
average in the last 72 years 4.2 percent
taxes added about another 2 percent to
that so you got to make over 6 percent
on your money on a long-term investment
to break even with taxes and inflation
and that's always been the case these uh
increases in prices have kind of looked
recently
in cars and houses and building supplies
and other stuff has woke people up again
on the dangers of inflation but
inflation's always been
there to erode your long-term investing
if you don't
do that and so in other words if you put
money in a cd
for 50 years at one or two percent
and inflation is running four percent
obviously you're going backwards and
that's not
handling your money well but your
emergency fund is not for that your
house fund is going to be spent as a
down payment on your house in the next
couple of years
right potentially yeah so inflation is
not going to eat that up because it's
not going to be in there long enough
where inflation gets you is where you're
dealing with something as a 10 a 20 a 40
year investment
that's where inflation gets you it
doesn't get you in 12 months
okay that makes sense to you
it makes sense yeah just house prices
have jumped up this year car prices have
jumped up
but that's not going to be a standard
way we're not going to see house prices
go up 20
a year for 10 years just wouldn't it's
just not gonna happen if it does we've
got other issues in this economy
and they're that's just structurally not
how we're wired in america
i just do not see that happening but
could we see it for
coming off the pandemic can we see some
of these things bump temporarily
you bet we have car prices are an
example of that
um and it's all it's more due to
shortages than it is anything else and
once the supply demand
curves equal out it's going to slow the
rate
of these price increases it's not a
bubble and it's not going to burst and
it's not going to go backward 50
or something like that five years from
now that's not what it's going to do
but this driving demand people sat
at home and spent no money except on
amazon for a year
and when they came out of their cave
they all went and bought a stinking
house
and they all went and bought a stinking
car by the way the lumber factories
weren't open making two befores
and the car factories weren't open
making cars so
we have this tremendous shortage of
supply
because the factories weren't operating
because there were little covets running
around in the factories and nobody
wanted to go in there
and so they were you know scared of
death and so we shut the factories down
we suppressed the economy
and that you know so there's a shortage
of two befores
not because there's this spike of demand
but because they weren't
making freaking tubaphores there's a
shortage of
glue to make plywood why
because there's a big run on plywood no
because the
clue factory wasn't open yeah okay it's
a simple thing
so it's gonna smooth out because they're
gearing up like crazy
there's a shortage on ammunition you
know why
biden you can't buy bullets
okay that's why and you know what we're
having all kinds of those of us that are
firearms uh
aficionados right now we're having to
check our
ammo because they're making ammo so
freaking fast at these factories trying
to catch up
that it's a lot of it's coming out
defective which is dangerous as crud you
can blow your gun up in your hand with a
bad piece of
bullet in there and so you know just got
an email on that this morning some
friends of mine just bought some bad
stuff and just about got killed with it
so um you know but the point is the
factories are gearing up like crazy
trying to catch up
and as they catch up you see how that's
working again it's going to smooth
everything out well i just what people
understand inflation can get really
scary to people and remember the media
exists to freak you out
okay that's what
if you listen close enough dave you lean
in you can literally hear the headline
going
and we're freaking people out here's the
deal all right this is a short-term
inflationary like the other focus
so now we have to have a new boogie
monster the locovit died
so now they gotta have a new bug boogie
monster let's see where we are next year
as to whether or not this is true
inflation hike versus just a short-term
spike
because of the whole supply-demand thing
this thing's going to even back out i
absolutely think that's true
and people need to relax a little bit
sit tight weather the spike in meat
prices and all the things that are that
are all having to do with
the distribution system and everything
kind of going offline
it's going to take a while this was the
biggest artificial shutdown
in the history of mankind of mankind and
so you don't just warm that machine back
up it takes a little while for it to get
humming well and some of these
uh corporations are more worried about
optics than they are actual
it's absolutely true and so they're not
reopening just because
one crazy you know activists or
something is gonna
[ __ ] about open people on twitter yeah
there's 17 people on twitter still
bitching about
this stuff and so they're all worried
about how things look you know how they
actually are they're not really worried
about somebody you're sick they're
worried about somebody bitching about
them being open that's right
that's what it is and so um these
corporations have no soul and they have
no principles no backbone
and so then that's what's happened in
these situations
and um and of course those of us that
did open
and did run our businesses we're trying
to kill our employees
oh yeah you know dave ramsey's trying to
kill his employees oh yeah so
which is kind of counterproductive
because i've got no employees i got to
go re-hire them all it's a pain in the
butt
so it's killing them off's a problem you
don't want to kill them off they're hard
to replace
dumb so that's what's going on though
man all right so ernest
turn off the news yes turn off the news
quit getting your financial advice from
fox news yeah
quick in your financial advice from cnn
for god's sakes those people on the tv
in front of you all have 120 000
student loan debt so don't let them talk
to you about economics yeah and they
don't even know what inflation is it's
only on the prompter in front of them
that's a fact they don't even know what
no would influence you ever
right you're getting financial advice
from ron burgundy
[Laughter]
what's wrong with this picture right
he doesn't even know it's just on the
problem
yeah and here's the here's the scarier
part that's dave let's give him full
behind the scenes
not only is it ron burgundy reading
something on a prompter
a 24 to 25 year old producer typed it in
there for him
yeah they don't understand economics or
inflation
see i'm old i remember jimmy carter i
remember real inflation
right that was real inflation that was
not a supply demand curve
thrown off by a pandemic that's right
economic suppression
that is that's a different thing we had
bad monetary policy over a decade
yes from the 70s up into the 80s and we
were jamming at 10 to 15 percent
inflation rate
per year for a decade there yeah i
remember that
interest rates at the height of that do
you remember that was the resulting
thing that
that ended the carter administration for
sure yeah
we had when i uh was 20
let's see 1981
interest or i was 21 inches i was
selling real estate interest rates for a
home
were 17 goodness graces fixed rate
17 and uh that was the end of it
and and let me just here's the
interesting thing three years earlier
they were 10. yeah wow
when i when i got my license at 18 years
old in september
i remember it went from nine and three
quarters to ten for the first time
in modern history we had 10 mortgage
rates and people were screaming
ready to jump out of windows sure that
the world was coming to an end and
little did they know it was going from
10 to 17
in only about 36 months yeah just crazy
yeah that's real inflation you don't
have to worry about on the short term
brother
you just don't have to worry about the
short term it's a long term where
inflation will kill you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host
ken coleman ramsey personality host of
the ken coleman show
where he talks about careers the path to
your
dream job yep getting in something that
you love and work that matters he's here
to answer questions about that
and will chime in with me as we talk to
you about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five brandon is with us in
lexington kentucky starting off this
hour
hi brandon how are you doing great dave
how you doing today
better than i deserve what's up hey
excellent um back at the end of february
i was in a car accident
where the airbag was actually
put in wrong airbag shot out the front
of the car the canister
flew backwards it took out my right eye
broke my neck i had severe burns it
degloved most of my face
um but that's pretty
traumatic um
yeah you're still healing big time
aren't you yes
there's a lot a lot of scars and strokes
and bruises um
but in probably 10 months to a year
um there will be a settlement where
conservatively it's probably around 5
million dollars after everything's taken
care of
attorneys all that i've never had access
to that kind of money
um and i want to be
you're covering your phone i'm not
hearing you i'm sorry
um i never have access to that kind of
money was the last thing we heard
okay yeah i've never had access to that
kind of money um i want to do
things the right way as far as taxes go
um
you know take care of myself my family
and i just wanted to see what the first
steps need to be and where to go from
there if you have any advice
oh my i'm so sorry what a horrible thing
to go through
huh um
so you have an attorney on your team i
assume
yes that is is he's advising you you're
going to get the money that quickly
um they've been going about 10 to
15 months typically um it's kind of open
and shut case
yeah i would think that but um wow
okay and how old are you
i'm probably 38 in about a week and a
half
what do you do for a living i've been in
the restaurant industry
serving bartending okay all right the
most recent
you said family are you married in kids
uh married and i have two wonderful
stepdaughters
okay that are 11 and 14.
well what you've been through is very
traumatic and
very dramatic um and so
it's going to uh and it's been you know
i can't speak to it as much as you can
brandon but i mean
uh if i get a hangnail i i i cry
so i can't even imagine with the pain
and all the things you've been through
and then the permanent loss of one eye
so you know you've got some uh
emotional uh and physical
healing to do from all of that uh
it's not a good time to be making really
big
decisions uh like i hit the lotto
kind of decisions uh and so i can tell
you how to do it over the course of a
long period of time
and then you've got to implement it so
here's a whole bunch of things i'm going
to throw at you and then i want ken to
speak to your career thing
number one i want you as soon as you're
able emotionally and physically
to develop a career track i want you to
develop a career track where you don't
need this money
if you don't need this money then it's
going to work
really really really hard for you and
and you're going to be
in a position of unbelievable wealth at
the end of this story
as a result of only five million dollars
because it can let me let me give you an
example okay you're 38
if you just never touched it and
invested it
and that's not what i'm going to suggest
by the way but if that's all you did you
put it in a mutual fund
series of mutual funds and it made 10 it
would double about every 7 years
so that means when you're 45 it's 10
when you're 52 it's 20.
when you're 60 it's 40
million dollars that's how
important it is that you don't go
through this money
and blow it all now we're not going to
do that exact plan
but you're going to put in place
something that gets the advantage of
that kind of thing
because to me a 65 year old with 40 or
60 million
feels a lot more exciting than a 38 year
old with 5 million
and i hope it does to you
that's where you're going if you'll go
get if you don't you know treat this
like
emotionally like woohoo i hit the
lottery i know you didn't hit the
lottery i understand that you've been
through a lot of pain
and i'm not diminishing that part of it
but you see what i'm saying you don't
blow this
which is why you're calling so thank you
so here's what we're gonna do
number one you put an investment person
in your corner
an investment advisor that has the heart
of a teacher
their purpose is not to do the investing
for you it's to teach you
enough that you can start to make basic
decisions on basic investing
and later on more sophisticated
investing okay
number two if you're going to do some
real estate you put a real estate person
in your corner
and if you're going to invest some of it
in real estate you would buy real estate
and that one's going to take you longer
than the other kind of investing
and you're going to pay cash for real
estate or that's for investment purposes
or you're not going to buy do you own a
home
uh no apparently okay then we're
probably going to buy a house out of
this
but something super conservative because
every dollar we put in that house is not
doubling every seven years right
and that's where we're going to go with
this so you begin to develop
and then you get a tax person in your
corner the same thing
with the heart of a teacher and then you
get an estate planning attorney
in your corner same thing with the heart
of a teacher
and you start to develop almost an
advisory board for brandon incorporated
and the advisory board is an investment
advisor a real estate advisor an
insurance advisor a tax advisor
and you start to put these people in
your corner and you can find most of
them on our website i don't i'm not in
any of those businesses
i don't want anything from you i don't
want to do any of it for you
but i want you to do it and let them
have the heart of a teacher and lead you
and then i want you to move into a
career ken
yeah i curious did you have something
you always wanted to do before the
accident something you thought about
uh honestly no i don't
all right so i've been thinking about
that i want to do something i just don't
know what i'm going to be one capable of
doing after all this is said and done
yeah that's my first thing is
you need to find out from your doctor
what if any physical limitations you'll
actually have because you're still in
the healing process
so i'd start with physical limitations
and then i began to look to the heart
and
answer this question who are the people
you most want to help
what are the problem they have or maybe
a desire that they have that you would
like to be a part of that solution
when you can answer those basic
questions right there you'll begin to
see hey this is how i want to contribute
so don't think about work anymore as
just work think about it as
how am i going to contribute and begin
that process
go to kencolma.com download the career
clarity guide and go through that
worksheet by yourself
then with some trusted people who know
you really well and it's going to begin
to give you some ideas
and then once you know your limitations
and what you need to do they get
qualified
that's how you begin that journey that
process and i agree dave
if he's working doing what he loves he's
already got all the money he needs
yeah hang on kelly's going to pick up
i'm going to put you through ramsey plus
with
financial peace university i'm going to
pay for it we don't need anything from
you we just want to help you sir
you call back as you're working through
this and i'll help you with it and
advise you as you go along
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at
five 825-5225 is with us in san diego
hey angelia how are you hi dave thanks
so much for taking my call i'm so
excited to be talking to you right now
totally nerding out but um so i have a
question for you
um i just got a big promotion at work
which doubled my income
uh so my husband that i combined will be
making over 250 a year
um so i was looking for some advice on
my roth retirement account i've got my
own roth fire array
and then through my employer i have a
raw 401k
and with our new income the 6000 i can
contribute to my runoff will only be
about 5
so to get me to my 15 right now
with my employer they match six percent
dollar dollars so that's what i am doing
but should i just
increase that to 10 um to get me to my
15
or is there another option that you
think i should uh look to
look at you can increase it if you want
you said you're married
your household income is 250. what's
your husband uh does he have 401k
available
yes so his 401k uh he's been investing
since he was 18. so he's got about 500
um in his 401k through work right now as
well
yeah but does he have a rock does he
have a roth there
um he has not switched over to the ross
just because
they just started offering it in january
and with
his age and how much he already has in
his traditional 401k
um i didn't know if it would be worth to
switch him over to ross like his new
contributions
how old is he i know he is 44.
absolutely his new contribution should
all go into that the old ones we can
talk about later that's a big move
because it's a lot of money and it'll
create it'll activate a lot of taxes if
he moves the old contribution but from
this point forward it should all be roth
so here's the rule match beats roth
beats traditional so the best thing you
can do is both of you get the match
then the next best thing you can do is
both of you max out roths
until whether it's roth 401k or roth
individuals
until you get to 15
of your household income now you both
put in a max of
19.5 and a 401k so basically 40
000 if you both max out your 401ks
you both max out your roth iras at six
that's another 12 so that should get you
there
okay and you know you in all of this in
good growth stock mutual funds with
great
long-term track records but we're trying
to get to 15
of your household income which would be
what 30
uh 37 000
and you can do that you can do that with
your 401ks
alone you know if you never do it an
individual roth
but that's now if your individual roth
obviously you can choose from 8 000
mutual funds your 401k may not have
great options
if you got better options then you know
we go with his you got better options we
go with yours or we go with individuals
i don't care where they are but roth is
what it all ought to be
plus the match that you're getting from
this point forward now i would not
convert his 500 to roth until you
have some extra money laying around
because that's going to activate taxes
but yeah that's you look at it as a
household situation and that's how you
do it
so very good work good job greg
is in raleigh north carolina hi greg
welcome to the ramsey show
hey thanks for having me i appreciate
you taking the call mr dave mr ken
glad to be on sure how can we help
well so my wife and i are in the spot
because we so so we've been doing
the steps we're actually through step
four we're investing 15
um we have six months uh savings stored
up
and we've got about an extra 10 000 now
probably by the end of next month it'll
be close to 15 because we get an extra
paycheck
um and our plan was we have two vehicles
that are older and cheaper and
they're paid for of course no no debt or
anything else other than house
um our plan was our family is going to
be starting soon
we need a family vehicle and so we've
been saving up for that
however one of the cars we have a three
thousand dollar car and we have a
fifteen hundred dollar car
the three thousand dollar car
transmission went on it so
looking like we gotta replace that and i
don't know should we
you know scrape some extra together go
up to twenty thousand twenty five
uh and get the family vehicle now and
then keep going with the fifteen hundred
dollar car
until we we you know save up and replace
that or do we just sorry
how much do you have in your emergency
fund uh and to our emergency fund we've
got about
25 20 about 25 000. how much do you
say for a car about 10 right now
so how did you get to 20
well that so that's what i'm wondering
because that 25
i'm wondering if we steal a little money
from the emergency fund
put it with the car fund to to replace
the vehicle now
what's your household income about 220.
um well i mean your
your emergency fund should not be below
three months of
your expenses so what is three months of
expenses for you guys
yeah three months of expenses probably
about 12
13 13 000. 15 15 is your minimum
emergency fund so if you move
if you move down an emergency fund and
move up a little bit in car and
immediately then
you're debt free right correct then
immediately you start
building that emergency fund back up and
building that car fund back up because
we need to get out of that 1500
car as well and you should do that at
light and
at breakneck speed with your income you
have fabulous income what do y'all do
for a living
yeah uh i work for an engineering
services company doing sales
she's the nurse okay um
so the other little aspect with all this
is
when we met she had a house then i i
bought a house
once we got married she moved in we
turned hers into a rental we actually
have a
third one as well that we have a rental
that's a rental as well
both of those two rentals we have about
50 down
pay but we do have mortgages on those
now i'm including the mortgage on that
in the emergency fund
number so that fifteen thousand for a
three months
is uh is includes the mortgages on those
as well
if you sold one of those could you pay
off the other one
yeah and and have the money to move on
up in cars right
yeah do it you need to move one of them
right now this market's hot
okay pick the one you don't like and
move it and let's let's clean this mess
up
because now you're sitting with two nice
cars paid for a fully funded emergency
fund and one paid for rental property
i'd rather be there than where you are
okay
that's a good point okay
thanks for the call bro appreciate you
joining us
so ken the um
when you've got a career that's cooking
like that it gives you lots of options
yeah yeah when you have an opportunity
to get promoted and move yourself up the
ladder
and keep financing the baby steps
and then when you have a situation like
the cars you can go do that get right
back into the emergency fund that is why
the great job is the big shovel it's a
game changer
riley is in utah hey riley how can we
help
hello sir i have a question for you i
have what i
would consider a very good job my wife
does as well
and i am wondering if i should quit my
job to
go to college if college is paid for why
are you going to college whether it's
paid for or not
i feel like right now my job is while it
pays for and has good insurance it's
kind of a dead end
there's not a whole lot of room for
promotion my wife's job
seems to be a bit of the same and i
really i have
no connection to it what do you mean
every day and i dread going to work
what do you make um between my between
my wife and i
no what do you make at your job
i make 22.85 an hour after
taxes and insurance i net about 34-ish a
month
right but here's the thing if you don't
know why you're going to college other
than
i have a dead-end job that's still not
good enough reason to go to college
you've got to have a reason
are you going to college to get a
specific degree that will then
qualify you to do work that you're
deeply passionate about
or you just think well if i go to
college i can upgrade my life
so i love automotive i went to a
two-year technical program for it
before i joined the military and now
that i'm out of the military i really
miss it
but i don't want to turn wrenches my
whole career so i've looked into it and
if i get a degree in it and i've already
been accepted into a program should i
choose to go
then i can go into more of the
management of the manufacturing of
diesel and automotive technology
all right so in that situation you said
it's paid for us if college is paid for
and it's the only way or the best way to
get you to that management
job in automotive absolutely do it but
you got to make sure that you can afford
to do it
not just afford the college got to get a
budget together and make sure that we
are living
while we're getting educated
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
todd and jamie are with us hey guys how
are you
great dave how are you better than we
deserve welcome it's
good to have you guys where do you all
live fort wayne indiana indiana oh fun
very cool welcome to nashville how much
debt have you guys paid off
seventy one thousand one hundred forty
eight dollars all right
very good how long did this take three
years good for you
and your range of income during that
time started it ended around a hundred
thousand
okay and what do you guys do for a
living um i'm in finance
and i used to be a printer but at the
same time my printing plan was closing
down i ramped up my side hustle and paid
off the debt as i was walking out the
door
oh fun what was your side hustle um
comic book shop
okay is that what you're doing full-time
now yep all right look at you
well done man that's fun what kind of
debt was the 71 thousand
our mortgage oh you paid off your house
yeah we're looking at weird people how
old are you two
i'm 45. i'm 47. awesome what's the house
worth
uh 230 somewhere in there yeah i love it
way to go youtube thank you very very
well done
how's it feel to not have a payment in
the world
amazing yeah excellent so
now that's sweet i mean you walk out
from the printing job
and pay the last payment on the house
well i paid it down so she actually had
to go through the drive through to make
the last payment
herself i wanted to go inside
but you know kovid i had to go through
the drive-through so it's kind of
anti-climatic yeah yeah i remember a
cartoon years ago
drive-throughs are at banks or where
cars go to see their real owners
you guys that's so fun
so what inspired all this what started
this all three years ago
um well like todd said he works in
printing and
um you know we just we knew it was gonna
end eventually
um just you know the whole book paper
industry
is just you know going away so we kind
of prepared ourselves
um for this moment um his plant
actually closed on the 23rd of december
and we made the house the last house
payment on the 28th five days later so
we just you know um we knew it was
coming we wanted to be prepared and we
didn't want to have to worry about
you know finding another income if we
needed to
you know we could just relax and breathe
wow
so when you decide to finally attack the
house what was a big sacrifice what was
something big that you guys decided okay
this is gonna kick start this or
something maybe you didn't want to do
but you knew you had to do i mean we cut
back on i mean just your basics going
out to eat and stuff like that but i was
working
pretty much 12 hour shift and i was
working a comic book shop on the side so
it was kind of like
time and you know time and family a
little bit
were you working for somebody else in
the comic book business or was that i do
i was a collector for probably 30 years
salad without selling anything i've
collected
so then i branched off branched off and
just started doing it myself
okay started selling so you're doing a
lot of it online then no i don't do
anything online oh you don't do anything
you built a uh you built a physical
location that people come to to trade
it's inside of an antique shop and i'm
all way in the back and i've got like 20
000 comics in the very back of it
and i run it out of an antique shop oh
wow that's amazing so then my overhead's
low and then i don't you know have all
the bills and
wow so what is the most expensive comic
book you've ever sold
um i mean i've probably sold seven eight
thousand dollar comics but there's some
worth a lot more
yeah oh i know they're out there oh god
i'm just saying that out of your
collection you sold one for seven or
eight grand
yeah what was what would be something
that would go for that um it was a star
wars number one 35 cent cover
okay i sold that years ago oh my gosh
i guess it's that's that's astounding
that's fun
that is very fun we turn his hobbyist
passion
the money is there it is that's how you
do it just like a ken coleman thing or
something said it a few times yeah
do do work you love oh yeah exactly yeah
and so does it just you still
just yeah yourself well the antique shop
manages the stuff when i'm not there
okay so it gives me the opportunity to
go hunt down comics and have a good time
good for you
yeah okay fun well way to go guys what's
this house worth
about 230 000. that's good yeah
that's very good and how did you get how
did you guys get roped in with us
i was listening for years and she
mentioned it one day hey dave ramsey and
then she got on board and i just
followed her down
i was like okay let's do this game on
game on all right
just like that let's knock this last 71
000 out three years later ding ding
house is paid for just
in time for the print shop to close yes
odd timing yes
yeah that's interesting wow good job you
guys
what advice do you have if somebody
wants to do this they want to get out of
debt what should they do oh just
like keep your eye on the prize the end
goal
i mean it just feels amazing to
go to sleep at night lay your head down
and you know you don't have to worry
about anything
it's just that that end goal and you
know just be honest with yourself and
your partner
and you know you know this is something
that's worth doing
and and just um pushing through and the
sacrifice is so worth it
i mean if you really think about it it's
just a small amount of time that you're
sacrificing
and you've got the rest of your life to
just you know live like no one else
yeah yeah that's good pay a price to win
live like no one else later you can live
and give like no one else
that's so fun very cool very cool so
you're still
actively adding to the inventory you
said you should go out hunting
oh yeah all over newestville yeah no
you've been all over nashville
we're not over national hunting
inventory so we're having a fun time
yeah
that's cool where do you find your best
stuff um it depends i mean
estates i usually buy full collections
so i mean
oh i typically go that route that's a
good yeah that way that sounds like
you're right
fun fun and you brought your daughter
with you yep yep all right how old is
she
she is 18. all right way to go and an 18
year old is named
casey casey welcome casey good to have
you very very cool
all right we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you because you've changed
your whole legacy
way to go that's very fun and an extra
copy of the total money makeover for you
to give away to someone inspire them to
do what you guys have done
uh it's worth it isn't it yes how's it
feel to not have a payment in the world
oh just
yeah just breathe easy i'm telling you
yes i love it all right todd jamie in
casey fort wayne indiana 71
000 paid off in three years making a
hundred a year count it down let's hear
a debt free scream
three two one
love it that is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
that's how it's done you know
sometimes when we talk to people that
want to open a business doing something
that they're passionate about
the biggest obstacle they have is
they refuse to start small
um we've got a sign up over here over
the top of a trunk of a car that says
don't despise small beginnings so true
and you know he put this in the back of
an antique shop so when he's gone
somebody's managing
the sales probably for very little is
just an arrangement with the landlord
there
and he's sub leasing and got almost no
overhead
yeah and so almost everything he makes
comes home
brilliant way to start to turn your
hobby
into a very lucrative business as a
first step that's exactly right and
here's the key
something you love so he's willing to
swallow his pride
and go to the antiques shop owners say
hey can i come in the back i just need x
amount of space
when you care deeply about something
dave you'll swallow your pride you'll
work those extra hours this was a side
hustle to get out of debt but now it's
become his full-time gig
that's the key when we talk about
passion you got to love it and you're
willing to suffer you're willing to
swallow the pride you're willing to
hustle
drive all over nashville to look for
inventory you know he's chuckling right
now
listen that's what you do because you go
i desperately would rather do that than
work for some jerk that just shuts the
plant down and i've lost my job
so i'll work harder i'll work smarter
see passion
gives you the fuel for that the fire to
stay with it long enough to figure that
out
but it's almost like you're to start
your playing around the fringes
you don't have to walk right out in the
middle of the ring with the spotlight
oh no just play around the edges yes
take the edges there's lots of money
in the edges yeah just go ahead and make
you a living in the edges yeah
you don't have to start in the spotlight
maybe the most amazing miracle on the
planet is watching a human being learn
how to walk
and they always crawl and they stagger a
little bit
then they start walking with some pace
and then they run
yeah not the other way around yeah we
got a toddler running around right now
oh my gosh once they take off they go
that's it oh my gosh
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five we're continuing to do
shows
on america's greatest
legal fraud it's kind of an oxymoron
technically but this is still a great
name
what is america's greatest fraud out
there that's legal
timeshares for sure
complete rip-off right we all know that
and yet people still get stuck in them
every day
and um so if you have been burned
by a time share you've had a horrible
story with a time
share or you have just gone to
one of those ridiculous
sales presentations kind of like getting
stuck in a prisoner camp
you know kind of like getting stuck in
something that you
a tiger cage and you can't get out and
you want to tell your story
we want to hear from you we want to give
you a place for your voice to be heard
because real people are who's been
getting screwed by these people
so if you've got a time share story
email us at
daveonair at ramseysolutions.com
daveonair
at ramseysolutions.com just put
timeshare rip-off story or whatever in
the subject line kelly will get back
with you
we're not going to tell you what to say
but we'll give you access to a
microphone
and a radio show where we can tell
people what's really going on
in that business well dave i don't like
you talking nasty about time shares i
sell time shares
you shouldn't do that you should get a
good job
your job sucks and your job is to rip
people off
you should stop doing that i'm sorry if
you don't like it
if you work for a payday lender you
should get a different job
your job sucks your job is to rip people
off
you shouldn't do that why is this hard
i mean there's this is an ethics problem
because
it's an immoral operation because of the
way the customer is treated
and the way they the way they stick it
to you
and so if you've had dealings with
westgate or diamond or
windham or you've had dealings with
marriott
or you've had dealings with any of these
folks where you're dealing with
time share the blue green folks oh god
help you if you got in that one
and uh just email us at dave on air at
ramseysolutions.com
we are going to continue to expose
america's greatest
legal fraud and oh boy have we got some
cool information about what's going on
behind the scenes with some of these
people
and these companies you are going to
love
the next show they're not but you folks
are
all right edgar is with us in fresno
california hi
edgar welcome to the ramsey show what's
up
how are you doing good i have a question
so this is my first time trying to buy a
home
and i'm 32 and i don't have no debt
and you drop the phone i'm 32 and i
don't have that was the last thing we
heard what happened
yeah you're having all kinds of trouble
here with your phone try one more time
sorry i said i've been uh trying to buy
a home for a year
yeah and the issue is not the crisis but
i didn't have any credit because
everything i've owned i
paid cash for good for you so now the
issue is
i've been trying they said we've been
looking at homes i know the house price
or the house mark is crazy
and we fell in love with a house on the
acre and
i'm debating what should we do should we
buy a house already build
yes or should we try to go buy a home
and build a module home on the land
uh you should buy an existing property
and if you're having trouble getting a
loan
with no credit if you have a good tax
return showing that you're making money
you can do that it's called manual
underwriting you have to find a mortgage
company that does that
churchill mortgage does they're one of
the ones that does that
um and here's the thing edgar modular
can
means a lot of different things yeah
there are some
home builders that are building with
components of the home
rolled in on a truck and stood up intact
together
like a wall system or a truss system or
something like that that's pre-built
that's
technically speaking a modular home
the trick is sometimes modular home is
code for
double wide yes and if it's code for
double wide you do not want to buy that
that's going to go
down in value 100
of the time double wides go down in
value sometimes the land
under them goes up in value faster than
the double wide goes down
and you make the mistake of thinking the
trailer actually went up it didn't go up
it went down
in value so if you can tell
if the consumer the next buyer can walk
up to the house
and tell that it came on wheels or that
it came in sections
because of the construction technique
notifies the buyer
that it is modular then you are not
going to get the appreciation and you
may likely get
depreciation loss in value on the
property
do not buy that and if you need
help with um you know manual
underwriting just get in touch with
churchill mortgage they can help you
it's a very good point that you to point
out because there are some companies
that are really coming into the
marketplace that are building nice stuff
and they're just building them in a
giant warehouse and pieces with real
carpenters
so it's real wood it's just they're
building it there and they're bringing
it out then they put it together that's
a very
that's a house yeah that even though
it's prefab or if you want to call it a
module it just means the way they're
putting it together but that's a very
good point
those are those are very affordable and
they're pretty well built
in some cases those small systems are
better than us really nice because
they're built
in a giant factory yes sir so that is a
very key distinction there and those
to me i think that's if i'm going
modular i'm going that route
yeah but but that's not what he's
talking about no he's not talking about
double wide
that's right and trailers trailers are
basically cars you sleep in
they go down in value yeah that's what
amounts to down
in value stay away from them and
churchill can help you and you know what
the interesting thing ken we're finding
is that
real estate agents around america are
lining up to work with churchill the
best real estate agents in america
are lining up to work with churchill
because of the service they're providing
and especially dave ramsey listeners are
working
having their agents work with churchill
because churchill can do
manual underwriting they can get them
the loan when they haven't had all the
credit lined up
and they've stayed out of debt like he's
done he's been mr cash off the grid guy
yep now you have to of course have a tax
return yeah to be able to prove that you
make an income
but that's you know back in the day we
used to and churchill does this and
again they work with the best real
estate agents in the nation
for this reason and so all you real
estate agents out there you need to
remember them
uh by the way but the best ones work
with them
and um but the
in the you know 1978 i get my real
estate license right a thousand years
ago
there were no pre-approved mortgages
there was none of this stuff where you
just walked in with a number and they
gave you a loan
a monkey can make that loan right and so
we had to actually do mortgage
people actually did underwriting that's
where the word comes from they
did the research on the individual to
make sure they could pay their bills and
we had to have them sign a vod
so we could send to their bank a
verification of deposit a verification
of employment a voe
that was mailed snail mail in those days
to your employer and they would send
back verifying how much you make and
that you work here
and verifying that verify mailed to your
bank and they've sent a
note back verifying how much is in the
bank and you know you pull up tax
returns and they show
that you've actually made money several
years in considerat you know in
you know continuous years and you just
verify
and you know verify length of time of
employment it length of time in a
certain career
and all of this work went into approving
a mortgage loan because it was a big
deal
back in the day when dinosaurs room
roamed the earth now that's how a manual
underwriting loan works is they're going
to do that exact same kind of thing
today of course it'll be done
with electronic it won't be done snail
mail and
um it's done very very quickly
but the you know with the advent of the
fico score and all of america worshiping
at the altar of the great fico
oh great fico you're our provider and uh
then
uh you know then everybody's gone to
that and the mortgage companies a lot of
people have
forgotten how to really do an
underwritten loan
and it's a shame but churchill can do it
and that's again why
one of the many reasons the best real
estate agents in the nation work with
them
so if you're a high quality real estate
agent you got to check them out
this is the ramsey show
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermsyshow.com
thanks for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host today
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money it is a free call at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
kyle is with us in charlotte north
carolina hey kyle how are you
hey i'm good how are y'all better than
we deserve sir how can we help
all right so i have a couple questions i
have a
house that my parents built and then
when they split up my brother stayed in
the house the house has been
put into my name mama says just for tax
purposes so
i want to sell the house while the
market is good which you don't really
want me to
so i don't want to do that but i'm also
going to start a business flipping
houses now it's probably not the best
time to do that
but i do have a line of credit against
my house because the house is paid off
so starting up businesses flipping
houses is very expensive so
a couple of questions should i move out
of the house and start my own i'm 30
years old
start my own life without that and is it
okay to use the heal off against the
house to start flipping
houses to do especially your expensive
business to get started
okay there's a lot going on here um yeah
the first thing is it sounds like
morally it's not your house
did she give it to you or did she just
deed it to you for her
she did it to me for her indeed for now
she says it eventually
i don't care get it back to her you've
got all the liability and all the
problems
and none of the benefits right just put
it just
quit claiming to eat it right back to
her and let her have her own house
and then you go about your business and
go about your life uh
which means you don't have any money
right right
and you don't have any way to borrow a
home equity loan
on a house you don't own right correct
yeah which you don't need to be
leveraging that house
especially if it's you don't need to be
leveraging it period but you especially
don't want to do it if it's really not
yours
morally because morally it's her house
that's what we're saying right
okay so we clean that part up now let's
go back to the other part about flipping
houses
this is what i did i used to buy
foreclosure real estate
in my 20s and i would borrow the money
to do it
and i would flip the house and make a
profit
and i would borrow the money to buy
rental properties as well
and ho in some cases hold them sometimes
it took a lot longer to flip than i
thought
um and i've done
in excess of 2000 real estate deals in
my life
so i've actually done for a living
what you're talking about doing so this
is not some
theory i actually did it right and
um uh
so and i went broke doing it uh
because i had borrowed three million
dollars after it was all said and done
and i had about four million dollars
worth of real estate and the bank
uh got sold to another bank and they
called our notes and we spent the next
two and a half years of our life
selling everything to to try to beat the
foreclosures
we became a foreclosure after we used to
buy foreclosures
and we lost everything by the time i was
28 had to start over that's the dave
ramsey story
so all of that to say uh you can
make money flipping houses in the in a
market as hot as this it's very
difficult
because the trick is buying it at a deal
in order to sell it at retail you buy it
below wholesale and you sell it at
retail like you do anything in business
right and um and so that's
very very difficult in a white hot
market where anything that comes on the
market no matter how bad how ugly or how
messed up it is is bringing premium
price
in two days and so it's just really
really hard to find a good deal on a
property
in a market like this so that's that's
uh uh thing number one thing number two
is
it's the the only way i would suggest
you do this
is with cash which means you've got some
savings to do
saving to do with your career before you
move on
to buying your first property with cash
and if you flip with cash
and in a market that's not quite hot it
can be done it's very difficult
it's a lot more difficult than they tell
you at the real estate seminar
where they where they charge you three
thousand dollars to learn how to do it
yeah kyle i want to know are you
planning to do a lot of the work
yourself are you you consider yourself a
carpenter a handyman
fix it upper guy yeah i am since i'm
still kidding by being in the
construction industry
is my passion as well today are you
currently
what is okay i'm sorry i have a hard
time understanding are you currently
employed in the construction industry
uh not in the residential industry next
okay
well i gotta tell you uh if it's me i'm
gonna start a renovation
uh handyman business because you need to
come up with the extra cash yes
right so i'd start doing that let me
tell you why uh
not only is it very practical for you to
make extra money to be able to save up
to buy your first house and cash flow
something really small
you're going to get the experience that
you need to do it for yourself and
somebody else is paying you to do it
and let me tell you something in
charlotte north carolina i would say
dave
that's very similar to nashville as far
as market size
economy you start doing bathrooms
a additions over garages someone else is
paying you you can make some really
really good money and again get great
experience
learn who the subs are because all of
those subs
uh those relationships and those
experiences and that money all has to
come together
i'd start a small business grow it slow
cash just cash cash cash and just put it
away put it away put it away
and before you know it you know two
three years from now you're doing
something you really love you might be
doing it full time now
and then you put away the money to buy
that first house and flip
i think that's the best path forward
dave because he enjoys it number one
number two he gets the experience he
needs someone else is paying for it i
love it
so kyle the rule is this and and i broke
the rule and you will break the rule
when you use borrowed money to buy a
property
you're not as careful and you pay more
if you're putting money that you've
saved over three years i've been saving
like crazy
and i've got to go buy this house and i
start thinking about i wonder what that
roof is going to cost
i got to put a roof on it you're going
to know what that roof is going to cost
before you buy the property
and you're going to know what the value
of that property is after rehab you're
not going to guess
yeah and you're not going to get in a
hurry and you're not going to get sucked
into a bad deal
when you're spending real money not
borrowed money
borrowed money makes people sloppy
they don't pay attention and they do
worse deals and that's how people go
broke
the number of people who use borrowed
money to flip houses and are still doing
it after a decade
is almost zero almost every one of them
go broke during that decade
it just doesn't work so if you want to
do
flips you can do it it's very hard
it takes a lot of work to find the deals
it won't work hardly at all in a market
like this
and you should do it with cash now if
you don't follow that
you're gonna get to learn the lesson the
hard way like i did
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text and
six gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Applause]
[Music]
the cost of college has gotten real for
really serious dollars
especially four-year universities you
need a plan for college
scholarships and financial aid are a
good plan they'll get you there
they're a bonus but saving money for
your kids college in an esa a 529
this is what parents do they want to
send their kids cool
pretty simple so you need to check it
out you need to talk with a financial
expert get an advisor in your corner to
help you get your 529 set up
if you want to do that you can get with
one of our smart vester pros
they are our vetted smart vester pros
we've added them we go through the
they're trustworthy
they're going to help you and they're
going to have the heart of a teacher
when they sit down with you
text the word invest 233 789
invest 233789
david is in albuquerque hi david welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks so much for taking my
call sure what's up
so my fiance and i we've both been
blessed to have
parents that espouse the same principles
that you teach every day
both of our parents grew up because my
dad would say
uh didn't make enough money to be poor
and so when we grew up
we grew up very frugal so now that my
fiance and i
have graduated college and don't have
any student loans or anything like that
we know what works but emotionally we
sort of have this itch to get some of
the things
that some of the finer things that we
didn't have growing up
so we know what to do mentally
but our our emotions are kind of you
know bringing us to the mercedes-benz
website
and looking at brand new cars so what's
your advice as far as getting
uh ourselves to motivate each other to
stay focused on that same path that our
parents were on
hmm how old are you guys
i'm 30 and my fiance is 25.
when you're getting married september
18th
congratulations that's wonderful thank
you
well um the bible says where there is no
vision
the people perish would you agree with
me that spending money that you don't
have and getting yourself deeply in debt
so that you're broke
would be a dumb idea
absolutely okay so to have a vision to
not do that
would be a smart idea so we need a
vision for
how we want our lives to look and then
is the
act are the actions that we're taking
congruent with how we want our life to
look
and so buying a car you can't afford
on payments is not going to give you
the life that you desire so what steps
what things are
do i avoid and what things do i do
that gives me the life that i want
that's a vision does that make sense
and so you know let me let me kind of
paint it out in other words you say okay
we're 30 uh and 25 when you're
40 i want to be an everyday
baby steps millionaire i want to have x
number of dollars in my 401k
i want to be able to go on some nice
trips
i want to be able to buy pay for dinner
at a nice restaurant
uh and and i want to have an emergency
fund in place and i don't want to have
any debt
if you lay those things out and say
that's my 10-year goal
then when you get ready to do something
you say is this adding to the goal or
taking away from the goal
right but if you just wander around in
our society you will end up
buying crap you can't afford with money
you don't have
to impress people you don't really like
if you don't have a plan
right right and again it's more of an
emotional thing because again you know
both our parents are doing very well and
we see the fruits of that
but again you know we just we just feel
sort of this urge to get there a little
bit quicker than we know it's gonna take
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good
yeah and you've mentioned the word
emotional twice and and so what dave's
trying to help you see is big picture
see your mom and dad
struggled mightily you said yourself
when you grew up
uh they had nothing and you asked about
motivation what dave just laid out for
you
david i want to make sure you caught
what he said okay
you got to have a vision for a future
and that'll take care of the motivation
so he was
he was describing your where and your
why where do you want to end up
why do you want to end up there that's
what he's laying out for you
well you get clear on that then the
motivation to sacrifice
to withhold what do you make is there
how much do you make
uh combined we make about 140 000. okay
goodness yeah okay
so if you had an emergency fund
and you had no debt and you were buying
your home you had a 15-year fixed and
you were paying it off
and you were saving towards retirement
and you wanted to spend two hundred
fifty dollars to go out to eat one night
you could do that easily in a really
nice nice restaurant couldn't you
yes sir okay so i'm not prescribing that
you have no life
i'm prescribing you have a life of
intentionality
not impulse and so if you act like a
child you're going to act like
most people and operate on impulse
but sharon and i do all kinds of really
nice
things david and it's not because i make
a lot of money although i do
it's because i make a lot of money and
every one of those dollars has a
freaking assignment
sometimes the assignment is generosity
sometimes the assignment is dave wants
to
have some fun or sharon wants to have
some fun sometimes the assignment is
uh future investing uh and but
every you know it's all just on a plan
and uh
you know you can have a wonderful life
meanwhile building a wonderful life
yeah but again dave the key word you
just said there was plan
you got a plan that informs the name on
every dollar
and people want to know oh i can't get
motivated can't get motivated well let
me tell you something
you're not motivated because you don't
have a very clear goal a clear direction
motive motive motive is the root word
there you gotta really lock in on that
so what's that desired future
when you both get really clear on that
then we can go oh okay
i know i really want a new mercedes but
that's not going to get me where i want
to go
and so you're motivated to sacrifice
you're motivated to be
when i get there i'll buy a new mercedes
yes
but that's right there is the key point
yeah
i mean but but right now i don't need to
even be on the website because it just
disturbs my brain well that's another
good point dave if i stare at
you know what if you're drunk you don't
need to go to bars right
but i don't need to be looking at 5
million homes all day long
because if i do i'll start to develop an
appetite for that but i
can't do it not not today so that next
book you might there you go
you know but that's a really good point
so hey rachel's new book know yourself
know your money
talks about talks about your family that
you grew up in and how it affects these
decisions and you kind of mentioned that
a little bit
i'm going to send you a copy of that and
we have a fabulous
know yourself money assessment for
couples and you guys i'm going to give
you
one of those as well i'm going to sign
you up for that and uh
you guys take that as part of your
pre-marriage counseling it'll print out
this
fabulous thing showing everything your
fiance
thinks about money the way they're going
at this and the way you're going at it
and i think it'll add a lot of value to
this discussion for you
because i think what's happening is is
that um
about the time one of you is being wise
and mature the other one's not and then
you swap places
and uh you gotta both get on the plan
and just go look
wisdom and maturity does not mean no fun
yeah it means higher quality fun it's a
really good point
i'm wondering dave if this sweet young
couple they watch their parents struggle
and sacrifice and now they're good
but he said something in the
conversation he said we want to get
there
faster i wonder if there's a little bit
of fear that oh i don't want to live it
out as long as my mama did we want to
get there we want to do better than mom
and dad i wonder if that's driving some
of this yeah
do you see that with young people i'll
help you with this you're blink you're
there
isn't that the truth you blink you're
there it's not it's
you're going to have plenty and you know
and
all along yeah at different stages with
different incomes and different net
worths
and different levels of investing and
different levels of generosity sharon
and i have had
the ability to enjoy money all along
yeah
but you don't you know if you're making
50 dollars he's making a hundred and
forty thousand
you don't go buy a uh a 12 million
dollar house
you know and so there's no sense on
being on the website there's no sense
watching the tv shows about twelve
million dollar housing truth i'm doing
good
no it doesn't do any good it's
counterproductive to what your goal is
now you may be in a place someday that
you have a house like that
but not right now yeah this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt
free stage brad and jamie are with us
hey
guys how are you doing great how are you
doing better than we deserve welcome
good to have you guys how much debt have
you guys paid off 196
302 in 27 months love it good for you
where do you guys live
memphis north of memphis cool okay and
uh your range of income during that 27
months
we started at 137 ended at
166. good what do y'all do for a living
we both work in the va okay cool well
it's great to have you guys what kind of
debt was the 196 000
uh well we were kind of normal dave we
had bit of everything we had the
we had lawn mowers for my
landscaping business we had tsp loan we
had credit cards
uh car rv all of it
wow yes two hundred thousand dollars
worth yeah
normal yes normal sucks unfortunately
yeah wow
so what in the world happened that lit
you guys up
i mean you must have sold a bunch of
stuff to do that in 27 months
uh yes and no um uh what got us started
we actually heard about you probably 15
years ago
and we waited and we actually got debt
free while we were in the air force
and we never got past baby step two we
did that
my behavior didn't change i wanted to
live and
enjoy the money right now i didn't want
to have to be on a budget
and two hundred thousand dollars in debt
later
i i used a budget the wrong way uh
jamie gave me the budget many years ago
and i started using it to say okay this
is how much is left at the end of the
month so i can afford that payment
and when it got down to where it was
less than 100 or 200 i said okay we
can't afford that next thing
and it got to where we were making
um too much money to be struggling like
that
we grew up both of us grew up where we
didn't have much
and god blessed us with such a large
income and we were squandering it we
were not
being good stewards and it started to
really hit me hard that god had blessed
us with all this income
and we weren't living right and we had
gone to get some tires from our
motorcycle
on that was also a motorcycle and uh my
son needed a pair of shoes
and when we were going down there we
said we have too much debt we're not
going to use this credit card we're
going down here and doing this in cash
and that was kind of the start of the
journey and when i couldn't afford in
cash to buy them shoes
i it just i i snapped i cracked because
this is this is insane i make this much
money i can't buy my son's shoes
and we got back from that trip and
uh about a week later my co-worker
actually he
brought you up on youtube i was like oh
i know who that is
and he started listening to it and i
just got intense it's like
i went crazy i started listening to
every single bit of every ramsey
solution
every other personality and and it got
me fired up uh-oh jamie
what did he do he went into overdrive
to completely gazelle intense uh did he
bring you with him
he did i tried struggling sometimes i
just wanted to see the attitude change i
wanted to see the behavior change
and it took a while for me to warm up
because i had seen him
yeah we can afford this yes work on it
we can do this and
i was hesitant i'm like i'll support him
but i'm like
i want to see it change i want the
behavior change
and uh i knew there was a light at the
end of the tunnel but it was still so
dark
so dark so desperate what all did you
guys sell
we tried to sell my subaru and we did
we were able to downgrade my car i now
have a
2010 honda civic crv
crv not bad and uh it gets me from point
a to point b
i absolutely love my little roller skate
as we call it
and that was the biggest thing did you
sell any of his toys like his motorcycle
no no did you sell the camper we tried
we tried twice to sell the camper and
it stayed on the lot for 90 days they
didn't understand why i wouldn't sell
and i just kind of checked it up as you
know what
god wants me to just work hard and and
take care of this thing
but it was insane though once we were
doing it god's way and we were
i was living on the budget and sticking
with it and godliness with contentment
is great gain and i learned a whole new
meaning of that verse and that's become
like that's date of my head this whole
time
um it's like money just starts showing
up everywhere
it was it took five years for my medical
retirement to show up for
the air force and it was three years
prior to this for three and a half years
and
during this shortly after we got this
started all of a sudden that showed up
i'll be
lump sum of money come in i mean i think
there was like thirteen thousand dollars
and just things like that just kept
pattern of course kovid uh
that we felt bad because it didn't hurt
us we ended up
making all kinds extra money we got
extra incentive paid because of that
she got a job because of it she works
with me now in i.t
oh yeah look i was curious how did you
go from 137 to 166. that's a good jump
that was mostly me uh i was working out
of one position and uh i've always
wanted to be an i.t i was in i.t for the
military and uh
kovit happened and there was special
there was special uh
incentives but it had to be temporary so
i left a permanent position
that was terrifying a temporary position
i.t
and before the temporary position became
non-existent there was a permanent that
opened up and i applied
wow leap of faith god blessed us
that's correct that's so fun you guys
how's it feel now that you're done
unreal was it worth it oh yeah
definitely i i i i if there was some way
that i could just gr drag somebody
kicking the screen but i know i can't
you've been trying to do that for 35
years now
but i tell everybody i mean do you have
no idea how much that
it was like it was i didn't realize how
much of a
not not like a noose around my neck
around our necks it was just
the debt is horrible and the minute that
we paid off the last debt it was like
that bondage just gone what was the very
first one you paid off
the little one actually it was one of my
mowers it was a walk behind 36 inch
full hydrostatic nice mower that i got
from my landscaping company
that one and the next one off almost
within the first two months when our
taxes came in okay all right so boom
boom and then you kind of got that got
you going
yes yes yeah it's getting a little
progress it helps it got hard though
yeah it got real
196 000 i guess so well we actually
we kind of topped off a lot higher than
that because overtime i at one point did
a hundred hours of overtime
within a two week period whoa and i've
that that about killed me
i said god let me see if i can do it and
there was people praying for me
and it was only by god's grace that i
had the strength because i was at work
four o'clock in the morning left work 8
30 at night
home by 9 30 back up again at 3 o'clock
in the morning to get back to work again
what was the direct i want people to
hear this because they just heard you
describe how hard it was
what was the direct benefit coming out
of that two-week period uh
more than quadrupled with my paycheck
yeah i mean i was blessed with the fact
that we just had blanket over time
because of covert because of
i was doing a big project upgrading our
com closets so let me tell you there's a
lot of com closets in that uh
hospital that have tears on the floor
because it was there's a reason why i
wanted to come here and do this because
i'm not very an open person i don't like
to be out in public a lot but
somebody else needed to hear this yeah
they they because there were so many
debt free screams that sent me into
tears i heard their numbers close to
mine i said
i can do this and it was halfway through
and it was just
painful so painful so tiring
that's great that's good stuff right
there so proud of you
so well done excellent excellent job you
brought the kiddos what are their names
and ages
this is michaela this is elisha all
right it's good to have all of you we've
got a copy of the
legacy journey for you that is
definitely the next step
in your process now you've changed your
life now you change your legacy
well done very well done and a copy of
the total money makeover for you to give
away and get somebody else going on this
so good stuff all right brad and jamie
mikayla
and elisha 190
thousand dollars paid off in 27 months
two and a half years
making 137 the 166.
did it man game on overtime whatever it
took
knocked it out count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream
three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
that's how it's done man i love it
very well done very well done
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today psalms 145 16-17 you
open your hand you
satisfy the desire of every living thing
the lord is righteous in all his ways
and kind
in his works my friend kathy said
nearly every moment of every day we have
the opportunity to give something to
someone else
our time our love and our resources
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run all the
time
you'll save even more this is a great
american company
if you need window blinds they're the
number one seller on the internet check
these guys out i've done business with
them at incredibleblinds.com
today's question comes from steve in
massachusetts i'd love to
move into a management position and i've
been working with my superiors to gain
additional training and certification to
be the best candidate for this position
i'm cautiously optimistic about this
opportunity
but they have a history of working with
employees to move up the ladder but
never
actually hiring them for the position i
know nothing is guaranteed
but how do i navigate a conversation
where i bring the subject up i don't
want to jeopardize any progress i have
made
but i also want to address this concern
you know steve i don't like you bringing
this
up i don't know where you're getting
your facts i don't know if you've been
able to do your own research to see well
they'll talk a good game but they never
actually move anybody up
and regardless of the scenario about how
you've come to this conclusion
talking to them about being concerned
that they're not going to promote you
is not going to actually get you the
opportunity to get promoted you have one
way to do this
and that is do all the things that
you're doing you're getting the
additional training
the additional certification you're
talking to leadership about it the only
thing i would add to this is
get it in writing and say hey if i do
these things will i
be in a place where i've got the best
chance
to win the position if they say yes you
do that
if they keep kicking the can down the
road you know that your suspicions or
that the rumors are in fact true and
you've now hit a lid at this
organization
and then you begin to look for something
else to move on to but to have a
conversation about
concerns about something that may or may
not happen
it's not going to help you go for it if
you don't get the shot then you decide
to move on
yeah there's not really a way to say to
your leader hey i've heard you don't
have integrity
and to have that help you with promotion
yeah
that's probably not going to work out no
robert is in mozambique hey robert how
are you
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
uh so i work for a company and
all of our jobs are outside of the u.s
because we spend all of our time outside
the u.s
all of our income is tax-free so i
qualify for the 3330 tax exempt where i
don't have to pay
any federal taxes uh for the year
so last year on paper i made about 12
thousand dollars
in actuality i took home about ninety
thousand
um but i want to start investing in the
401 thrift that my company offers the 19
500 cap will i find any penalties or
anything
if i invest more than what i actually
claim on paper
and should i choose the roth or
traditional
so that because of the tax situation you
can invest up to your earned
income into a roth
or into a traditional or into the 401k
but if you do if you're showing an
earned income on a u.s tax return of 12
000 that is your cap
gotcha yeah you can't put more into a
401k than you got paid
okay but the so the the tax papers show
that i made
the 90 000 but because of the
exemption for working out of the u.s
the actual adjusted well it may be that
they count that earned income you need
to check with a tax advisor in the u.s
then to find out you could check with
one of our
endorsed local providers that does taxes
but base if they're counting that as
earned income even though it's not
taxable income it could be earned income
and not taxable income
but uh for instance you cannot give you
an example
if you if you live on disability income
uh the irs for tax for purposes of
putting money into an
uh retirement account that does not
count as earned income
if you have uh investment income that
you live on
that is not earned income for purposes
of doing
uh an ira and so if you've got a million
dollars in the in mutual funds and you
pull a hundred thousand dollars off the
investment every year but you don't do
any
you don't have any income that you earn
from a job
or anything else then you cannot do a
retirement plan on investment income it
has to be on earned income
so it may be the 33 30 incomes
considered earned income and then you
can max out
and if that's the case it certainly
would be sorry i don't
know the answer to that i'm not a tax
guy
but check with one of our endorsed local
providers at ramseysolutions.com and
they'll help you walk through that
sarah is in new york city hi sarah
welcome to the ramsey
show hi thank you so much for taking my
call i'm
super excited to be on the show today
sure um so yeah
i am a recent graduate of a master's
program
and graduating with about 58 000 in
student loan debt
um despite the debt you know luckily i
was able to uh
increase my my income through like a new
job like substantially
um however with this increased income i
just feel like
there's a lot of upcoming things i'm
thinking about for example i'm getting
married i want to buy a car i need to
buy a house
pay back my student loan debt and i'm
just having a hard time
really trying to figure out how to
balance like the new income i'll be
making
we'll see cool what will you be making
financial
um so my base will be about 165
and i'll be getting stock and things
like that so my total will be to 240.
good for you way to go excellent when
are you getting married
um right now it's set for june 4 so that
next summer
a year okay what does he make
he he's in real estate so it fluctuates
last year he made
160 and now it fluctuates though
cool well we teach a process called the
baby steps
and it's the order of attack that is the
shortest distance between where you are
and wealth okay and we've done it for 30
years and
millions and millions of people have
used it to become millionaires
so it really does work uh it's not magic
it's hard work
but um the first thing you do save a
thousand dollars that's kind of a
no-brainer in your situation and the
second thing is you work to become
debt-free as fast as possible
so making 240 how fast we're going to
pay off uh 58 000
in debt really really freaking fast
before you talk about buying a house
um and you're you're gonna do that in
just a few months
i mean because you're used to living on
nothing
that's true yeah now do you have a car
no i don't not at all yeah so like the
only
uh debt i have is from the student loan
oh but you're
okay you're in new york city so uh yeah
exactly where are you leaving the city
i'm thinking of moving elsewhere to sort
of cut down on the rent i've been paying
um as a student but it's still pretty
much up in the air
but your career is there yeah my my
career is here but i can move to jersey
or like somewhere else
i got you i would do that dave i if you
can move to jersey and save on rent
and you're gonna write i would use
public transportation absolutely that's
what you've been doing all these years
and that's not a problem there i mean
you you can't you just catch the subway
to get around don't you
yep exactly perfect you're right if
you're in jersey you can ride the train
in or
wherever i mean and it's it's perfectly
fine
i would do that for a short period of
time and let's get the debt cleaned up
and get you an emergency fund of three
to six months saved
and then i would save up and buy a car
and then i'd start saving towards the
house
and somewhere in there we've got to stop
and put enough money in the bank to pay
for the wedding
yeah i think the biggest issue is like
for example like my my family
like i don't come from a family with a
lot of money so when it comes to the
wedding will probably
be much pretty much be me and my fiance
covering the whole cost yeah so how much
are you going to spend on the wedding
as of right now like i i want to stay
under 15 000. and i
i think we that's a comfortable number
but it's still
something okay let's pretend for a
second let's pretend for a second
let's pretend you make 240 000
and you need 15 for a car and 15 for a
wedding
and 60 to pay off student loan debt
that's 120.
you should do this and that's six months
of your income
yeah you have to live out of that and so
but the point is by next june
you should have accomplished all of
those through all of those goals
it would be very reasonable to have 120
000 out of 240
in one year wouldn't it yes
so that's that's where you got to go
that's the way to go ah
that puts us hour the dave ramsey's
showing or the ramsay show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
you